[Musique]
chacun son tour pour eux c'était surtout
jeudi dernier voyons donc ce que sera le
réveillon du 1er de l'an pour leurs
aînés ou aux leurs parents
pour nous rien on l'offre était déjà à
noël en fait derrière maintenant pour le
réveillon comment je crois chez moi mes
parents ce soir pour rire et bien rire
point n'est besoin d'être très très
riche il est vraisemblablement trois
amis on dirait que le médian a commencé
le réveillon a commencé alors qu'est ce
que vous avez prévu à des unités
pourquoi ce déguisement pour allonger
les amis enfin dans quelles conditions
ce serait bien on va se passer vous
allez vous avez que chez nous à la
maison mais épargnez moi cette attache
fort de ces gens pour des masques triste
afin de mieux rayons bien parce que les
masques et restent font rire malgré tout
l'habitude de voir des visages agréable
on aime bien avoir donné des masques
plus drôle ça aurait un peut s'amuser à
quoi exactement grands boulevards un
effort des restaurateurs
nous avons maintenu notre prix l'année
dernière déjà c'était un succès malgré
les hausses
et puis mon dieu on entre à d'autres en
cours de la soirée au cours de la soirée
votre menu est à 65 en 2008 à 65 francs
c'est quoi une bouteille de champagne
est bien la bouteille de champagne sera
dans l'ordre de 2 39 francs de prime
sous les deux bons de et peut-être de
champagne si comme le dit la chanson
vous avez laissé vos illusions entre
pigalle et blanche
ce sera peut-être dans cet établissement
un établissement insolite dans ce
quartier devenu le haut-lieu du strip
tease
ici rien de semblable la calme et
reposante ambiance d'une taverne
anglaise nous n'avons pas fait choses
particulières exprès pour ester même
passion le menu sur le mal et oui c'est
derrière nous vous avez envie prennent
traditionnel la gym et chevreuils
le foie gras filet de sable même sort
il est bien aidé par l'état
en fait penser tendue certains
entendront sonnés les douze coups de
minuit au travail comme c'est typo du
parisien qui ont composé une page
spéciale pour vous
[Musique]